on this episode we do it again
this is
ask Gary B everybody this is gary
vay-ner-chuk and this is episode 202 of
the askgaryvee show i've seduces kicks
get in here Stefan feeling pretty good
about these and when with the blue shirt
along with it India is here and we are
very focused on a 2:02 call-in show
we're bringing it right back all of you
hated on it we made some adjustments we
think we've got something India are you
ready to get into the call-in cha we
weren't done yet Oh outsourced to robots
you know it's like that's the future oh
you got very upset about what happened
episode you hundra no it's actually kind
of nice or what you're just so busy with
yeah like I have like it's kind of early
all right let's do it over time are you
ready for the show
very good Andy Andy this is on you like
are you ready to take responsibility if
this is glitchy didn't like the cadence
they didn't like the chop we think we
got it all right operator let's do it
episode 202 of the askgaryvee show
facebook live you are the backbone of
the callin and live episode nine four
nine seven nine three seven six one one
call in the show and we'll get the first
call in one second but if you're not
following me on Facebook Stephane let's
do a nice little edit here let Zachary
enter design something not like your
father
let's get some pretty here that says
facebook.com slash Gary please and link
those links up on YouTube and Facebook
when we post it well on Facebook that's
kind of weird like anyway on YouTube
make sure you're following because
Facebook live will be the backbone of me
doing this show um oh by the way I have
an idea this is ad hoc even though we're
filming it it'll be in the show this is
not really for the show give me one
second actually know what black and
white this out you don't usually do that
do that for me right now
um I think we should do a commercial
something screwed up
you're in trouble right I love it so
while you crash that out while you panic
I'll tell I'll tell you these guys are
you dead anyway
yeah it's penny my dad everything I can
do but like oh yeah what so force quit
yeah I love it
cuz right before us talking the guy yeah
okay I just talk about tech team how
many exactly do you think people are
gonna be calling in I was like a lot
it's gonna be a lot of calls in a short
amount of time he's like all right went
to Dave the show Oh wah wah wah wah all
right so what's gonna happen now oh okay
I'm gonna stall here while you do this
all right
India find a question um yeah so we're
gonna go to a logical way call it we
have a new number no no we can't do the
old-school way I think that thing was
really working well it's broken we broke
it didn't break it yet you know so
easily oh I like I can't even I can't
even it oh [ __ ] I can't fire to shut
down let me show you how you do it it's
very easy go boom
you hold it you hold it good what's the
problem you're loose enough I mean cool
but then alright but what we can still
use the Google Voice number I don't want
I want to use this thing yeah who always
worries that Andy you ask a question you
go think I'm not using Google Voice I'm
gonna use that thing is that the guy
calling I love it good good hustle way
to watch you keep doing your thing we'll
do our thing
you talk about it well I mean look I
think I think what I would do is
truthfully a lot of M&A mergers and
acquisitions I would go and look at the
anchors and the music leaves and and the
the after schools and the things that
are emerging in the marketplace and
realize that what I have is a business
model that is cold or not working as
well and not rolling and what I what I
show that's what I have an issue and
what I have an advantage in is that I
have dollars and assets and money from
Alibaba and other places that I can
deploy and so I think when your core
business is not driving upward mobility
in growth in your company the thing you
do is you leverage that asset to try to
build up your future and so my answer
would be M&A and I think to Marissa's
credit current CEO I have a lot of
respect for her and I think it was a
tough gig that she jumped into she went
out and did that and bought tumblr for a
big knot and you know to me in hindsight
if she would have been able to buy
Instagram instead of Facebook buying it
though I'm sure Kevin wouldn't have sold
him Yahoo the way he would have to
Facebook there was definitely you know
other you know I do believe that when
Marissa became the CEO there was
probably a moment there where she could
have bought snapchat for a billion or
two but then the question becomes when
you buy these hot things on the way up
do they stop becoming those hot things
once they go and get cashed out there's
not the same energy and so um the other
thing I would have thought about is
hardware I'm very obsessed right now
with the notion of hardware I think
Facebook should absolutely don't worry
about the cost I think that Facebook
should absolutely make a television for
example and so I think Yahoo could have
made a television could have made a
Netflix competitor I didn't like your
reaction already worried about the cost
and so the biggest thing I would say to
all of you to make this a little bit
more relevant to so many that watch why
don't you focus on the following if
you're in a business that has a
situation where it's not growing as well
you need to kind of disrupt yourself and
try to make new revenue angles and try
to do different things if you stay the
course and try to do incremental things
that grow your business that becomes a
vulnerability so if you're in a three to
four year funk where your business is
flat you have to really change the
business not just do what you're doing a
little bit better for example Wine
Library one thing I've always debated
that if we capped out our growth and
winds up is to really build out gourmet
library and become like a supermarket
and sell cheese and gourmet meats and
things that nature that's a big change
than just doing wine selling a little
bit better doing a little bit better on
the email service adding a couple more
selections or changing the pricing
strategy on the core business so if I
was Yahoo CEO a year ago and just trying
to grow the business not taking any the
Wall Street dynamics into play which
Marissa had to I would have done very
drastic things and hardware would have
been at the forefront
I think phones are too hard I think
televisions are easier and so what I
would have done is I would have
made a yahoo television that was
unbelievable would have bought a TV
producing company company that makes TVs
put Yahoo at the forefront of brand and
then build it over the top Netflix like
business and produce original content
that would have driven into there
because look Amazon and Netflix are now
making some of the best television in
the world that means anybody can
Facebook snapchat anybody can and that's
what I've done it would have probably
then reached out this guy named Gary Vee
and had give him a late-night show that
would have worked some things Annie you
ready go
number same number good nine four nine
seven nine three seven six one one here
we go all right Paul from unknown caller
to accept press one random Pedro yeah
this is Gary Vaynerchuk you're on the
askgaryvee show episode 202 how are you
oh my god good now you're my you're my
man my Jesus I appreciate it man Pedro
what can I help you with where are you
from and what's your question
so I'm from Portland Oregon um I'm the
social media specialist of murdered
Porsche Ducati um and my question is
about live stream okay so as far as
preparation for live streaming if you're
going to do periscope or snapchat how
much do you need to be prepared for that
you know I think that but and thanks for
the question it makes a lot of sense
obviously when you're an entrepreneur or
personal brand I actually think the more
ghetto the better you know the more real
there's so many other platforms your
Instagram photos your Facebook posts
there's a lot of places to go polished I
actually think live streams big upside
is actually just the real and the raw
and the lack of preparation is really
attractive and has been the reason
people loved reality TV and the reason
they would love periscope now when you
work at a big company like you and
others you need to be careful there's
something in the background is there is
there a document on the desk that people
could see you've got all these things
that you have to worry about that big
companies worry about so you need some
level of preparation but I think that's
awareness to what could happen versus
actually prepping you know what I mean
right yeah perfect most of our stuff
pretty much all of our good stuff is on
on a fly you know always man great
Pedro always I'm gonna I'm gonna go to
the next call I appreciate you watching
brother I love you thank you for that I
mean look the bottom line is that people
are always going to be more attracted to
the authentic there's an absolute place
for the polished movies you know TV
listen I think YouTube is an incredible
look we're doing dailyvee polished
because I believe in the strategy in a
world where now I believe YouTube videos
are gonna be very easily consumed on
televisions all across America I think
it's a good strategy that phone cut you
got a call coming any how's it going
that's all right there we go um I think
it's super important to recognize that
real and authentic is just as
potentially uh important as polished and
I think way too many creators and and
video tog refers and people that make
videos always overthink that they don't
understand that the that the raw can be
just as good as the the glossy it's like
fashion India like a great suits great
but a little bit of swag in the t-shirts
great too let's go to the next one
that's right how from unknown caller
Nick this is Gary Vaynerchuk you're on
episode 202 the askgaryvee show who's
calling and where you from hello hello
Gary yes hey what's up Gary this is Alex
what are you doing man I'm doing super
well Alex where you from I'm from San
Diego love it
everybody's very lazy in San Diego don't
you agree Alex totally agreed the bunch
of party people and fought had hard your
business here I agree man you need to
move to New York I wish but it's too
cold for me I'm originally from Brazil
respect Alex what's your question what
can answer for you
so I'm an IT consultant and I'm kind of
struggling on going to the next level of
just being me guys consultants to
actually creating a business and a brand
unfortunately I'm usually knowing like
the IT guy yeah the PC guys yep and a
thought but I don't care to them good
money yep but how do I move from being
the PC guy actually
having a business the name and throw in
well what do you want the booty good
Alex what do you want the business to be
like what do you want to sell it psyche
consulting an IQ support and I
commandment Donna you on your own gig
and you want to build a personal brand
so that clients then come to you and
then you can build employees underneath
you at first you'll do your own work and
then you'll get other people and you'll
build a firm like I did with vaynermedia
right correct you've got to put up
you've got to buy good I'm putting to
work but it's just me and my name and
I'm kind of struggling and well that's
because thinking the business yeah
because actually a bit but me yeah I get
it I mean like the way you got to do
that first of all is produce content
become bigger of a name have put out all
your best advice blog on medium put out
Instagram tips do white papers on
SlideShare do Facebook lives periscopes
make content make content make content
show your expertise have inbound
business and just like with vaynermedia
people want to hire Gary Vaynerchuk but
Gary Vaynerchuk is not available like
it's vaynermedia but guess what Gary
Vaynerchuk was available in two thousand
nine ten eleven and twelve and then I
made enough money to hire other people
in Gary Vaynerchuk wasn't available so
right now don't stress about the
semantics whether they want you or your
business they you don't have you don't
have the money or the need to hire a
bunch of people yet create such demand
that you take those dollars and hire
people and then just tell new clients
it's my expertise deliver to my
employees but you don't need me to
physically fix your PC got it got it
now real quick question you always say
that Facebook is doing much better for
ads and Google ad do you still believe
that you think I should if I were to run
some ads like should it go you should do
me you should you should do you should
do both I think Google search is great
for the business you're in
I do think Facebook is better for
content and branding you should do both
but first start making a lot of content
I need you blogging on medium.com about
your thoughts of PC and your thoughts on
i.t and your thoughts on tech in today's
society over and over and over again
content content content video written
form audio SoundCloud anchor all of it
it's all about the content Alex thank
you brother thanks for being on the show
let's get on to the next call Andy I
don't know if you got it figured out yet
but I think oh my god I'm getting
excited from Kyle Kyle Kyle turned down
your audio how are you oh we lost them
you didn't figure out the hack because
Kyle gave up and hunger I owe Kyle
listen Kyle's making your game look bad
Andy India actually I found a new thing
for you yeah good news
computers have not taken over your life
yet no I know you are um but what's
really cool is that we can in these
in-between moments where funny things
like what's going on with Andy happens
we could do fun little banter and you
can do little questions and things of
that nature behind you a little cross
it's like a holding a little thing brush
like a bit of a show in the show cool
yeah okay Andy what's going on you got
in it
oh here we go van [ __ ] dick hello this
is Gary Vaynerchuk here on episode 202
of the askgaryvee show who's this and
why are you from happy Gary to dismiss
Toby and I'm from Vancouver
Dana how are you good so I have a
question for you
and my question is I'm breaking into the
online market I have made courses before
but I took from tribal blades and then I
come darn it I'm so sorry I'm so sorry I
was just too choppy she was breaking
into online courses I could hear it but
she was also breaking up and I'm so
sorry I hate this but I have to navigate
the cadence and the flow of the show and
it was just too choppy and you can't you
can't figure out choppiness I know we're
not doing it the way we're not screening
calls and I think we should continue not
to screen calls I know a lot of you're
like screen calls and do this I get it
but this is how we're gonna do it you
know that's just the way it's gonna be
all right
call from unknown caller hey this is
Gary Vaynerchuk you're on askgaryvee -
OH - who's this and where you from and
please turn down your computer what have
you
Hey hey cam cam what's up baby is this
cam new it I can't believe I got on no
camp area or whistles can dude
cam where are you from Oklahoma City
love it brother what can I help you with
yeah so I'm currently working on a book
and I'm like interviewing different
entrepreneurs like what it allows you to
give to someone that's trying to get a
hold of like influencers and stuff like
that twitter twitter twitter twitter
twitter twitter twitter twitter twitter
period twitter no linkedin no cold
emailing it's not gonna work
go figure out the five hundred people
you want to interview go see what
they're tweeting about whatever if you
want to interview Cam Newton go look at
Cam Newton's last ten tweets
try to jump on the last thing he's
talking about and add value to the
conversation say like yeah or disagree
or no way or whatever you want to go
with it
create some context and so don't ask for
the interview right away get into a
little banter build up a little rapport
this takes a lot of work cam this is
five seven ten hours a day every day for
a month but you get then you go in for
the ask you get a little context with
these people you ask them to interview
them they've been talking to you about
sports or wine or candy or sailing or
surfing or raising children over the
last month now they got a little context
for cam on Twitter and then cam goes in
for the ask and one out of every 80 of
those unbelievable people will say yes
so if you think about 80 people getting
one - say yes and you needing 20 people
that's an unbelievable amount of people
that you need in your ecosystem right
then you're talking about a 1600 people
that you're heading up which is going to
take you months but it's putting in the
work and that's how you'll actually get
them got it yeah pretty sure no worries
brother
cam from Oklahoma City let's go - next
one huh Roberto this is Gary Vaynerchuk
from the askgaryvee show episode 202
roberto blake a big fan always supported
me I appreciate you I'm glad you're on
how you doing yeah I appreciate it man I
missed you at Big South yesterday well I
wanted to act like a super important
question about a business decision
trying to make let's do it you're the
person who can answer well here we are
episode 202 the askgaryvee show coming
through in the clutch right on okay so I
am working on a YouTube video SEO video
guide that helps on my audience who are
struggling with this and a lot of my
friends are giving me advice
I should pre sell it okay a little
awkward about selling something that I
haven't made because I feel awkward
about I want to just deliver on
something deliver the value I feel like
why should I sell it if I haven't made
it yet
oh you know what buck on that I think
look a lot of people that watch me and
hear me and feel like they know where
I'm gonna go with this answer may be
confused by this I'm very comfortable
with you pre selling it as long as you
feel like you're actually gonna deliver
on it if you feel like it's actually
gonna happen and you're not taking
people's money
like I think pre selling something and
then not delivering in two ways one not
delivering and like being a criminal and
stealing people's money I don't think
you're gonna do that and I actually
think it's unacceptable to also even
return the money because you're not a
goddamn bank and it would have been much
better for them to have it in their bank
account than you so you just have to
100% make sure you're gonna actually
deliver and the big vulnerability
because I know you a little bit and I
know you'll deliver on that too the
problem is if you lose energy or some
other amazing opportunity happens
tomorrow right if I email you tomorrow
and say I want you to be the new
official co-host of the askgaryvee show
with me but you have to work ten hours a
day when we're not filming doing XY and
z but you've got to go deliver on this
guide what's going to happen roberto is
you're going to [ __ ] the guide over
the next month or two because you're not
gonna have time and it's not going to be
the thing that you actually thought it
was going to be because you'd still be
you know finish your word and so the
vulnerability of pretty selling is not
delivering to the capability that you
have set in your mind because you don't
know what's going to happen tomorrow got
it got it that is exactly what my
concerns were and you really were really
good at you know figuring that out and
yeah you do know me a little bit so that
was perfect thanks so much thanks for
watching the show know what I need to do
now good brother take care all right
changing lives and DK on episode 202 so
right there the mouth was that it was
the zero mouth do you rock the mouth um
so actually you know what I got to find
a good cadence in between these calls
while Andy struggles and makes episodes
awkward this would probably be you know
we could actually do we could do a
little quick little topics quick hits
like the the player that got hacked
yesterday right before he got drafted I
like how people were confused and
thought that he posted that like like
people you hacked I'm like yes
act like yeah act like being cynical of
somebody getting hacked is when you say
something racist or inappropriate or and
then you're like no no I didn't do that
my you know and you can send a call at
any time no I didn't do that my intern
oh nice job maybe my intern did that you
don't you don't get hacked when you post
something that cost you eight million
dollars in 40 minutes
silly oh I'm not holla it hey this is
Gary Vaynerchuk these askgaryvee episode
202 what's your name and where are you
from
hey this is Calvin Wayman from the San
Diego's in social media marketing world
hey Calvin how are you doing well
brother good welcome my question is my
question is after you have come up this
super successful book number four launch
at what point do you now set your sight
on book number five that's a great
question big thing and why are you
asking that because I think that's the
more interesting part of this question
for me well but I'm just thanks for
sitting like the minds of successful
people once they got how long they duck
in their own success yeah when they go
through the next thing cool well that's
a great question Calvin I would tell you
and these guys can say this especially
when they all kind of like maybe India
really who's in the Vayner world more
than the rest of the gang Calvin I'll
tell you ah it was crazy what happened
inside my body when you said basked in a
success like I am zero capability of
basking in the success and I wish the
camera was 360 right now because all my
team except for Andy who's worried about
screwing up the show the three of the
rest of them were all shaking their head
because they know way more than anybody
that's watching right now that there
wasn't even a remote moment not a
celebration we have a dinner we need
together right I suck at celebration man
I don't have my sets my eyes set on five
right now I've got my eyes set on making
vaynermedia huge building more
businesses making smart investments
helping my investments build their
businesses getting credibility as a
great business man while I'm out of Gary
Vee mode for a little bit putting out
good content continuously upping my game
in my distribution of my content
so there's no book 5 but what I'll tell
you and Calvin thanks for calling what
I'll tell you is that I am always always
on to the next thing and never I mean as
a matter of fact I would actually argue
that this is a slight vulnerability of
mine I actually think it would probably
been smart to have a dinner with all of
us especially Andy and Alex and like in
all of us really to just be like hey
that was a nice launch no we don't have
that as a matter of fact let's make it
really intense
today's AJ's last day at vaynermedia I
was at a business meeting at a breakfast
spot this morning with a client I looked
over and AJ was there with Hyuk in and
made to Tyler and everybody was
celebrating
AJ's Tyler get in here real quick it's
the perfect timing
watch that why wasn't I invited to a J
celebration breakfast this morning
ok great get out of here and so like I
mean what's up witches got it and so
what's really interesting about that is
like there wasn't even a consideration
Tyler AJ's former assistant my current
teammate with India assistant like like
there was even considered think about
this this is my co-founder bruh little
brothers last day at Vayner they have a
symbol
this wasn't a one-week trip this was a
simple 90 minute send-off breakfast and
we didn't even consider for me to be a
part of it yeah like I you know it's
funny we don't celebrate the and it's a
celebration by the way it's not like a
sad thing like it setting I'll be with
AJ tonight which is great second a draft
but like even we sold a piece to the
business like we forced ourselves like a
year later we went to like Atlantis in
the Bahamas we thought we're gonna
really celebrate but we just became
degenerates and gambled for like thirty
nine straight hours and even like barely
even talked ability was that I'm just
not good at celebrating Calvin and and
and by the way I'm not so so that that's
a good idea as a matter of fact I
guarantee that you'll see a blog post
for me whether it's a medium or whatever
it is of the day six years from now of
finding celebration that's what it's
gonna be called finding celebration and
it will talk about me not being happy
that I was so extreme to the non
celebrating aspects of business I think
you should celebrate the good things in
life I think it is a miss on the way
that I navigate the world it still
doesn't come natural
me it still isn't even though I know
this I'm trying to sell myself right now
but I still can't get there and I'm
always following this over this this
says celebrate this that's heart and gut
this is still not saying celebrate and
so I can't celebrate and honestly if
this never says celebrate and I take
last breath and I think about it for a
second I won't regret it because I
always listen to this
but this understands that it's not
necessarily the best move and I think it
would have been really nice if we all
had a nice dinner and said talk to war
stories out remember that time the
person canceled the order at the end ha
ha ha you got want to know what is it
you need to be sad
what are they saying oh they're loving
it
all right good yeah wanna call Oh from
unknown caller
hey this is Gary Vaynerchuk and you're
on the askgaryvee show episode 202
what's your name were you from Daniel
from Miami Florida how are you I'm great
Daniel Passover thank you brother you
too thanks for being on the show I'm
always on the show virtually uh so I'm
not intact I'm actually a songwriter I'm
releasing an album and I'm trying to
avoid you know spending money in ways
like hiring publicist just afford them
time to really ramp up my social side
what I've been doing is I've invested in
several giveaway items trying you know
accumulate a street team which is work
and I was just calling to find out if
you had any additional ideas because you
will hear about me sooner or later
because this record will will get hurt
but I just don't want to ask your
opinion well thanks and I'll give you
some opinions that I'll even throw out
something that will give you if you want
and you might have noticed in the last
dailyvee we featured Ron Gilmore juniors
music if you want to reach out to d-roc
and talk about some of your music if you
want to have some of your music featured
in an upcoming dailyvee i'm not sure
what kind of music it is or what you
know d-roc and Andy's ear
sorry for nakata-sensei arabic rap
arabic rat great I think you've been
really cool you got it
the craziest part was I was actually
[ __ ] pumped I was like yes Arabic rap
I know exactly the kind of intense scene
anyway one I'd love to offer you that
because of a fan of the show we'd love
to give you some exposure so speak to
them let's see if that's a fit here's my
big plug influencers influencers
influencers I think you took a very
smart tactic of street teams I think
books and albums when they do that do
quite well I think the biggest arbitrage
for attention at the lowest possible
cost right now are influencers if you
can get people to do skits or other
things on Instagram with your music I
think you would crush and so I think if
you spend two hours a day just reaching
out to people based on hashtags on
Instagram so you go to Instagram you
search hashtags and then you engage with
people that are putting out stuff around
thematics
of either the names of the songs or the
genre of the music or things of that
nature I think that you could really
have a major impact by getting some
influencers on board to give you some
Aquarius and exposure to your music
what about TweetDeck do you think I
should continue doing that because I am
engaging with people through yeah okay
I'm a yes but I think Instagram is a
better push platform than Twitter which
is why I'm pushing you that way I would
also document the journey of releasing
an album I would write at least two to
four articles of the journey of
releasing an album on medium.com
because they're editors there pick some
articles and they populate them to the
top and I think there could be some real
opportunity for you there as well I
would also reach out to places like
HuffPo Forbes Business Insider cold send
them an email and say would you like me
to write a piece original for you on one
musicians point of view on releasing an
album in 2016 2017 all of them are
always looking for content I believe
that's a very inexpensive quick way for
you to get exposure to a crowd that
might be reading for business or other
things but all everyone loves music and
you're getting awareness got it got it
totally um how can I get in touch with
the rock Riccardi Rock yep d Rock d-roc
K at vaynermedia com okay and would it
be okay if I send you a signed copy of
my
album and maybe a boat that would be
amazing work with d-roc he'll figure
everything out and I wish you well
Daniel thanks for listening and watching
thanks brother awesome good show think
we got better we made a quantum leap
from 200 to 202 but that's actually up
to you that's the question of the day we
need feedback as we go into this new
frontier so please leave your two cents
on the show you keep asking questions
especially recall and I'll keep
answering them